.
Diese Kinder werden zu
reichsten Menschen der Welt gehören.
Mein Name ist Rebja,
ich werde zwölf Jahre alt.
Ich möchte mal
Wissenschaftler werden.
Ich möchte gerne
Unterstufenlehrerin werden.
Ich will Schreiner werden.
Ich möchte Tierärztin werden.
Tierärztin.
- Tierärztin.
Profifussballer.
- Profifussballer.
Fussballprofi.
- Fussballstar.
Ich will in einer Bank arbeiten.
Was möchtest du
in dieser Bank machen?
Geld verdienen.
Mal abgesehen von den Fussballprofis
verdienen Angestellte in der Schweiz
mit die höchsten Gehälter der Welt.
Das monatliche Bruttoeinkommen
beträgt umgerechnet 6'655 Euro.
In Österreich mit 3'724 Euro
und Deutschland mit 3'535 Euro
sind die Durchschnittsgehälter
wesentlich tiefer.
Noch eindrucksvoller sind die Zahlen,
wenn man
das Vermögen genauer anschaut.
Gemessen am durchschnittlichen
Nettovermögen pro Erwachsenen
ist die Schweiz
das reichste Land der Welt.
Gemäss Global Wealth Report
der Credit Suisse von 2019
betrug das Medianvermögen
in der Schweiz pro Kopf 227'891 ¤.
In Österreich waren es 94'070 ¤.
Und in Deutschland 35'313 ¤.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Wir haben keinen Zugang zum Meer,
wir haben keine Bodenschätze,
aber wir haben unseren Wohlstand
hart erarbeitet.
Vielleicht hatte
die Schweiz einfach Glück.
Sie war nicht in Kriege verwickelt.
Das Wichtigste ist die Lage.
Sie erklärt
den Reichtum der Schweiz zu 90 %.
Der heutige Reichtum wurde grössten-
teils schon im 19. Jh. angelegt.
Es gibt nicht den einen wichtigsten
Grund für den Reichtum der Schweiz.
Man muss differenzieren und
die Gründe an mehreren Orten suchen.
Die Welt ist zu komplex
für einfache Antworten.
In diesem Film wollen wir
ein wenig Licht ins Dunkel bringen.
Wir hinterfragen Mythen und Vor-
urteile und stellen die Thesen vor,
die uns am meisten einleuchten
oder überraschen.
Wie z.B. die Blaue Banane.
Die Schweiz ist heute reich,
weil sie seit Langem Teil
des europäischen Städtegürtels ist,
der sich von Norditalien bis England
erstreckt.
Man nennt ihn die Blaue Banane.
Es ist wirklich erstaunlich:
Sie ist seit 1'000 Jahren das
Rückgrat der europäischen Wirtschaft
und wird es sicher auch bleiben.
Dort wurden die meisten Erfindungen
gemacht,
dort ist die Bevölkerungsdichte
am grössten.
Die Schweiz
war immer Teil dieser Blauen Banane.
Deshalb war sie immer
Teil dieser Wachstumsregion,
die auch auf globaler Ebene
absolut einzigartig ist.
Die Blaue Banane
ist ein Modell aus dem Jahr 1989.
Der Franzose Roger Brunet
zeigt darin
den wirtschaftlich erfolgreichen
Raum auf,
der sich von England
über die Benelux,
West- und Süddeutschland, die Schweiz
bis nach Norditalien erstreckt.
(Straumann) Als Teil
dieser dynamischen Wirtschaftsregion
ist man in einen sehr dynamischen
Wirtschaftsprozess eingebunden,
wo man Ideen austauscht, Technolo-
gien übernimmt und weiterentwickelt,
exportieren kann.
V.a. ist Arbeitsteilung möglich.
Das fördert die Verbesserung
und Spezialisierung.
So sehen wir heute: Die Schweizer
Gebiete haben sehr klare Stärken.
Basel hat z.B. Pharma,
Zürich ist sehr stark in
der Informatik und im Bankenwesen,
St. Gallen
war lange Zeit ein Textilzentrum.
Da zeigen sich
sehr lange Traditionen.
Einleuchtend, gewiss.
Trotzdem: Wieso ist die Schweiz dann
reicher als ihre direkten Nachbarn?
Der Vergleich mit Deutschland
ist unfair.
Der richtige Vergleich wäre der
mit Baden-Württemberg.
Man muss berücksichtigen: Das
eine Land hat ca. 80 Mio. Einwohner,
die Schweiz ca. 8 Mio.
Es ist viel einfacher,
ein kleines Gebiet zu verwalten
und weiterzuentwickeln
als ein grosses Land,
das historisch ein enorm grosses
Gefälle zwischen Ost und West hat -
nicht erst seit der Wende,
sondern seit dem Mittelalter.
Der Buchdruck wurde in Mainz
entwickelt, nicht in Mecklenburg.
Deutschland,
Österreich und die Schweiz
sind unterschiedlich stark
in dieses Modell eingebunden.
Während fast die ganze Schweiz
Teil der Blauen Banane ist,
sind es in Deutschland v.a.
die Gebiete im Westen und Süden.
Österreich wird nur im Westen
von der Blauen Banane gestreift.
Wir sind wohl
die privilegiertesten Bewohner.
Wir haben
ausgezeichnete Bedingungen.
Ob man in Salzburg,
Stuttgart oder Zürich wohnt,
spielt überhaupt keine Rolle.
* Leises Stimmengewirr *
Warum ist die Schweiz so reich?
Was denken Sie?
Ähm ...
Sie dürfen
frei von der Leber weg sprechen.
Ich kann nur sagen, was ich höre:
dass es Ausländer gibt, die
ihre Konten in der Schweiz haben.
Das ist wohl das,
was einem als Erstes einfällt.
Zum einen wohl durch die Banken.
- Durch die Banken.
Man hat immer wieder
von den Nummernkonten gehört.
Schon ...
Man schleppt wohl das Geld dorthin.
Der Mann mit dem Koffer.
Der Mann ist Ausländer.
Im Aktenkoffer hat er Geld.
Sein Ziel: eine Schweizer Bank.
(Frau) Was bedeutete
das Bankgeheimnis?
Sehr viel europäisches Geld aus
Deutschland, Frankreich, Italien,
Spanien oder Grossbritannien
war auf Schweizer Banken hinterlegt.
Wir schätzen, dass 80 % nicht
an die nationalen Steuerbehörden
gemeldet wurden.
Insgesamt über 1,5 Billionen
allein europäisches Geld.
Aus der ganzen Welt
waren es über 2 Billionen.
They love me,
all my people stand with me.
Ferdinand Marcos and the First Lady.
(Zaki) Lateinamerikanisches Geld,
Geld aus dem Nahen Osten und Asien
und aus Russland war
v.a. aus politischen Gründen hier.
Aus Angst, im Heimatland
konfisziert zu werden,
oder aus Angst vor Regimewechseln
oder Kriegen.
Es gab fast keine Alternativen,
weil andere Finanzzentren weniger
unabhängig und neutral waren -
oder auch weniger professionell.
Die Schweiz hatte diese unglaubliche
Position mind. 40 Jahre inne.
Es war einmal ein Bankgeheimnis.
Es wird wohl bald zu Grabe getragen.
(Englisch)
(Journalistin)
Herr Bundesrat, worum geht es ...
Die USA und
später auch die europäischen Länder
setzen die Schweiz unter Druck.
Seit 2009
gilt das Bankgeheimnis praktisch
nur noch für Schweizer Bürger.
Glauben Sie mir: Die Geschichte ist
für alle alles andere als einfach.
International
sind die Schweizer Banken heute
grösstenteils
zur Transparenz verpflichtet.
Was auch immer die Bevölkerung sagt,
das Paradoxon der Schweizer Politik
ist,
dass die direkte Demokratie
immer an zweiter Stelle kommt.
Der Druck der Supermächte,
der die Schweiz von aussen bedroht,
ist immer stärker.
Als die Steuervermeidungspolitik
sehr politisch und gefährlich wurde,
fast ein Krieg mit den USA oder
den europäischen Ländern drohte,
hatte die Schweiz keine andere Wahl,
als das zu tun,
was die Supermächte verlangten.
Es wurde für ein kleines Land,
das keine Atommacht ist, unmöglich,
ein Steuerparadies zu sein.
Die Verbindung zwischen Atommacht
und Steuerparadies
ist eine perfekte Korrelation.
Als kleines Land musst du dich
von diesem Geschäft zurückziehen.
Das ist besser so.
Die Bedeutung des Finanzsektors
ist in der Schweiz gross.
2009 betrug der Anteil an der
gesamten Volkswirtschaft knapp 11 %.
Zehn Jahre später,
also nach Ende des Bankgeheimnisses,
immer noch knapp 10 %.
Zum Vergleich: In Deutschland
ist der Finanzsektor mit 3,9 %
weit weniger wichtig.
Die fetten Jahre sind vorbei.
Die Schweiz befindet sich
in einem Normalisierungsprozess.
Es tut mir leid, das zu sagen,
aber es ist wahr.
Ich übernehme die Verantwortung
für diese Vorhersage:
Das Bruttoinlandprodukt pro Kopf
wird in den kommenden Jahren sinken.
Die Bedingungen
sind schlicht mehr gegeben.
* Dumpf prasselnde Klänge *
Wie sieht die Schweiz
nach Ende des Bankgeheimnisses aus?
Nicht alle Experten
sehen die Zukunft so düster.
Ich bin überzeugt, dass die Schweiz
weiterhin wirtschaftlich
sehr attraktiv und stark sein wird.
Dass man die Bedeutung des Bankge-
heimnisses stark relativieren muss,
zeigt sich jetzt.
Das Bankgeheimnis
ist mehrheitlich weg
und es gibt
keine Verarmungstendenz.
Gerade die Region Zürich
blüht neu auf,
da endlich andere Branchen
Platz haben.
Man muss aufpassen:
Es entstehen immer auch Kosten,
wenn es etwas zu leicht geht.
Es ist eine Art Monopolstellung,
dadurch wird eine Branche
sehr träge, verpasst Innovation,
und v.a. haben die Banken
auf dem Arbeitsmarkt
sehr viele gute Leute
aus anderen Branchen abgezogen,
weil sie viel höhere Löhne bezahlen.
Das habe ich selber erlebt.
Gut ausgebildete Ingenieure der ETH
waren plötzlich bei einer Grossbank.
Das ist volkswirtschaftlich
nicht besonders ergiebig.
Und einfach das Bankgeheimnis haben
und Geld entgegennehmen und anlegen
ist nicht das,
was ein Land dauerhaft reich macht.
Es uns z.T. viel mehr geschadet
als genützt.
* Leise hektische Klänge *
Was also haben wir
bis hierhin gelernt?
Das Bankgeheimnis ist das Erste,
was vielen in den Sinn kommt,
wenn man über den Reichtum
der Schweiz spricht.
Natürlich stimmt die These,
dass es Einfluss
auf den Schweizer Erfolg hat.
Jedoch scheint er über lange Sicht
viel kleiner zu sein,
als man landläufig vermutet.
Einen ungleich grösseren Einfluss -
erscheint uns -
hat die geografische Lage
mitten in Europa.
Ein glücklicher Startvorteil, auf dem
die Schweiz dann aufbauen konnte.
Wie sah die Schweiz überhaupt aus,
vor mehr als 700 Jahren?
Der Rütlischwur von 1291
ist ein Gründungsmythos.
Die heutigen Kantone
Uri, Schwyz und Unterwalden
versprechen sich
gegenseitige Unterstützung.
Immer mehr Städte und Regionen
verbünden sich in jenen Zeiten.
Ein aussenpolitisch anerkannter
Staatenbund
existiert aber erst ab 1513.
Die Geburtsstunde
der alten Eidgenossenschaft.
Die nachfolgenden Jahrhunderte
sind kriegerische Zeiten.
Die Eidgenossen erweisen sich
als besonders zähe Kämpfer
gegen die Habsburger und Burgunder.
Schon bald gelten sie als unbesiegbar
und sind fortan
als Söldner sehr begehrt.
Das Söldnertum war
ein sehr wichtiger Wirtschaftszweig
für die Schweiz.
Junge Männer vom Land waren
einer der wichtigsten Rohstoffe,
den man exportieren konnte,
den die hiesige Landwirtschaft
nicht absorbieren konnte.
Mit den fremden Solddiensten
haben viele Menschen hier
sehr viel Geld verdient.
Es gab Personen,
die solche Kompanien bildeten
und sie ins Ausland vermittelten.
Sie wurden dafür bezahlt. Sie wurden
reich mit diesen Geschäften.
Aber auch die jungen Männer selbst.
Es war relativ lukrativ, sich
als Söldner ins Ausland zu verdingen
und dann eine Pension zu bekommen.
Damit kam man weiter
als mit Ziegenhüten auf dem Berg.
* Glockenbimmeln *
Komm doch mal her, Peter.
- Was wollt ihr?
Das Söldnertum
war eine wichtige Grundlage
für die spätere Entwicklung
der Schweiz.
Zum einen half es Familien dabei,
grosse Vermögen zu bilden,
zum anderen haben
diese 350'000-500'000 Söldner,
die es über die paar Jahrhunderte
hinweg gab,
später
kommerzielle Geschäfte getätigt.
Einige wurden zu Kaufleuten,
die aus dem Solddienst heraus
Absatzkanäle für Waren
aus der Schweiz erschlossen.
(Frau) Der Handel war
eine internationale Angelegenheit.
Unsere Vorstellung,
dass erst im 20. Jh. internationale
Handelsketten aufgebaut wurden,
ist schlicht falsch -
das funktionierte bereits vorher.
(Straumann) Die Schweiz
hat natürliche Vorteile.
Zwei sehr wichtige Flüsse,
Rhone und Rhein, fliessen durch sie.
Der zweite grosse Vorteil
sind die Pässe.
Die Pässe haben dafür gesorgt,
dass es nur zwei bis vier
grosse Übergänge gab
zwischen Norditalien
und dem nördlichen Teil Europas.
Zwangsläufig
wurde der Handel kanalisiert
und floss entweder
in der Nähe der Schweiz durch
oder sogar durch diese Gebiete.
* Dumpfes Grollen *
* Lauter werdendes Rauschen *
Auch der Bau von Tunnels
und der Eisenbahn
wirkten sich positiv
auf die Schweizer Wirtschaft aus.
Und das nicht nur
wegen des erleichterten Transports
von Menschen und Waren.
Für diese Grossprojekte
waren oft immense Summen notwendig.
Dies beflügelte
die Schweizer Kreditwirtschaft
und somit das Bankenwesen.
Der Mangel an eigenen Rohstoffen
war nie ein Hindernis
für den wirtschaftlichen Erfolg
der Schweiz.
Es gibt keine oder kaum Rohstoffe
wie Öl, Kohle und Eisen.
Aber die moderne Literatur
zeigt deutlich:
Wenn man zu viele Rohstoffe hat,
ist das eher ein Problem -
denken wir an Saudi-Arabien.
Sehr schwierig, neben dem Ölsektor
eine gute Wirtschaft aufzubauen.
Für Europa - nicht nur
für die Schweiz - ist speziell,
dass alle Gebiete sehr früh
versuchten, Rohstoffe zu veredeln,
um die Wertschöpfung zu erhöhen,
zu exportieren
und sich zu spezialisieren.
Das ist, was Länder reich macht.
Der Anteil der wichtigsten Branchen
am Bruttoinlandprodukt
setzt sich wie folgt zusammen:
Den grössten Anteil hat
die Herstellung von Waren mit 18,7 %.
Handel und Reparatur
machen 14,8 % aus,
wobei der Rohstoffhandel
eine grosse Rolle spielt.
Banken und Versicherungen
haben einen Anteil von 10 %.
Einen überraschend kleinen Anteil
hat mit 2,9 % der Tourismus.
* Leise gläserne Klänge *
(Frau) Die Schweiz
hiess zu Beginn diese Ausländer,
die unsere Berge liebten,
willkommen.
Zwar nicht aus tiefstem Herzen, wenn
man den alten Geschichten glaubt,
aber sie merkte schnell:
Man kann mit diesen Menschen
gutes Geld verdienen.
Obwohl wir nicht sehr freundlich
waren, kamen sie trotzdem.
Es gibt hierzu einen schönen Witz:
Ein Engländer stand im Berner
Oberland nach einer langen Wanderung
an einem Bergsee.
Er zog sich
bis auf die Unterhose aus,
schwamm in die Mitte,
zwei Bergbauern kamen, sahen das,
der Engländer bekam einen Krampf
und schrie: "Help! Help!"
Da sagte der eine Bauer zum anderen:
"Du, der hätte auch besser
Schwimmen gelernt statt Englisch."
Und trotzdem
wurde dieser Sektor wichtig.
Er beschäftigt
über 4 % der Beschäftigten
und trägt knapp 3 %
zum Bruttosozialprodukt bei.
Den grössten Anteil
am Bruttoinlandprodukt der Schweiz
hat das produzierende Gewerbe.
Maschinenbau und Pharmaindustrie
sind die Zugpferde.
Interessant ist, dass beide Branchen
auf denselben Ursprung zurückgehen:
die Textilindustrie.
Sie ist
schon vor der Industrialisierung
Motor der Schweizer Wirtschaft.
In der Schweiz setzte relativ früh
eine Protoindustrialisierung ein -
die Industrialisierung
vor der Fabrikindustrialisierung.
Das ist Heimarbeit
mit einem Verlagswesen,
den Ferggern,
die durch die Landschaft zogen
und die Rohstoffe verteilten
und die Endprodukte einsammelten.
Das war eine wichtige Erwerbsquelle
in einzelnen Regionen.
(Originalton) Im Nachbardorf
arbeitet in einem alten Haus
die Weberin.
Aus 1'000 Stoffresten macht sie
die farbenreichen Teppiche,
die uns
an der Fiera so gut gefallen haben.
(Wecker)
Es war eine gute Möglichkeit,
in den Wintermonaten
noch zu arbeiten,
wenn die Landwirtschaft
keine oder weniger Arbeit bot.
Es war ein guter Zuverdienst,
weil die Landwirtschaft
z.T. nicht so viel abwarf.
Die Textilindustrie war der
Leitsektor der Industrialisierung.
Sehr früh begannen Unternehmen,
Maschinen herzustellen,
die diese Mechanisierung
der Textilindustrie vorantrieben.
(Originalton)
Ganz ähnlich wie bei alten Spinnrad
wird die Flocke ausgezogen.
Und wie Menschenhände
einstmals spannen,
arbeiten heute zahlreiche unendlich
fein konstruierte Maschinen
mit Tausenden von Spindeln
rascher, exakter, rationeller.
(Tanner) Ausserdem galt es,
die Textilien zu färben.
Das ist die Teerfarbenindustrie.
Daraus entstand die moderne Chemie.
Teerfarben hatten auch medikamentöse
Wirkung, wie man herausfand.
Daraus entstand dann
die pharmazeutische Industrie.
Was die Energieversorgung
anbelangte,
waren diese Flussläufe
in der Schweiz wichtig.
Man begann, Turbinen, Generatoren
und Elektromotoren herzustellen.
Eine aufstrebende Industriebranche,
die damals Weltspitze war
und sich sofort ins globale Ge-
schäft, in den Weltmarkt einklinkte.
Die Textilindustrie
sorgt für einen regelrechten
Industrialisierungsschub.
Schon Mitte des 19. Jh.
ist die Schweiz nach England
das am stärksten
industrialisierte Land Europas.
Begünstigt wird diese rasante
Entwicklung durch Einwanderung.
Im 16. und 17. Jh. erreicht
eine protestantische Flüchtlingswelle
das Land.
* Leise sirrende Klänge *
(Originalton) Vor 300 Jahren war es,
dass sich 250'000 Menschen
auf den Weg machten - einen
unsicheren und gefährlichen Weg.
Von Fluchthelfern
über verschneite Alpenpässe geführt,
in Frachtschiffen versteckt
übers Meer,
ständig bedroht
von den Häschern des Königs,
der das Kapital,
das diese Hugenotten bedeuteten,
trotz allem
nicht ziehen lassen wollte,
ihr Wissen,
ihre Fähigkeiten, ihr Geld.
(Tanner) Die Hugenotten
waren Glaubensflüchtlinge,
die im katholischen Frankreich
erst toleriert,
dann aber vertrieben wurden.
Sie kamen unter Lebensgefahr
in die Schweiz.
In der Schweiz war das
durchaus eine grössere Sache.
Das führte dazu,
dass sich in ganzen Dörfern
die Bevölkerungszahl
kurzfristig beinahe verdoppelte.
Viele dieser Hugenotten
waren unternehmerisch begabt.
(Straumann) Es waren häufig
gute Handwerker, Kaufleute.
Sie brachten neue Fertigkeiten.
Und sie hatten v.a. Beziehungen
zu Rohstoffen und Absatzmärkten.
Die Hugenotten brachten die
Uhrenindustrie in der Westschweiz.
In der Deutschschweiz brachten sie
Seiden- und Baumwollverarbeitung.
Die Textil- und Uhrenindustrie
waren in der frühen Neuzeit
die grossen Pfeiler
der industriellen Entwicklung.
Das ist zu einem ganz grossen Teil
dieser Einwanderung zu verdanken.
Die Schweiz
war lange ein Auswandererland.
Bis in die 1880er-Jahre
wanderten mehr Menschen aus als ein.
Diese Entwicklung
drehte sich dann um.
Die Einwanderung
wurde dann wichtiger.
Und man kann sagen: Die Schweiz hat
unter dem Strich davon profitiert.
Es gab immer wieder Wellen
von Abschottungstendenzen,
wie wir sie bis heute kennen.
* Akzentuierte Streicherklänge,
hüpfende elektronische Klänge *
Unter dem Strich
war es natürlich genau das:
die enorme
wirtschaftliche Verflechtung,
aber auch der Import von Know-how,
von Erfahrung und Wissen.
Selbst wenn wir die
sog. niedrige Einwanderung nehmen,
Menschen, die sich hier
ein besseres Leben erhoffen,
sind meist sehr motiviert
und bauen sich hier etwas auf.
Wie wir bislang gesehen haben,
ist die Schweizer
Wirtschaftsgeschichte
eine fast schon
märchenhafte Erfolgsstory.
Doch wo Licht ist,
ist meist auch Schatten.
Erfolgsmodell
ist eine Selbstnobilitierung,
man beweihräuchert sich und sagt:
"Wir haben es sehr gut gemacht."
Nun kann man zuerst
auf die Verteilungsfrage schauen.
Da sieht man, dass das,
was als Schweizer Erfolgsmodell
gepriesen wird,
keineswegs für alle so aussah.
Gerade bei der Arbeitsmigration
zeigt sich diese Brechung.
Die kamen natürlich
in die Schweiz,
weil es
ein attraktiver Werkplatz war.
Was sie da aber vorfanden,
waren sehr häufig Arbeitsausbeutung,
schlechte Anstellungsbedingungen.
Sie wurden auch ausgenutzt.
Das würde ich nicht einfach
als Kollateralschaden abtun
am Rande der grossen Heerstrasse
des Fortschritts,
sondern würde
das sehr viel ernster nehmen.
Man musste im Wettbewerb
mit England bestehen.
Die englischen Firmen hatten
zunächst viel bessere Technologien.
Und man konnte nur überleben
und exportieren,
wenn man die Lohnkosten
sehr tief hielt.
In den Fabriken arbeiteten
auch Kinder und v.a. Frauen.
Frauenarbeit wurde ohnehin
sehr schlecht bezahlt.
Zusätzlich sorgte die dichte
Besiedelung immer für Nachschub
an billigen Arbeitskräften.
Das war auch eine direkte Koppelung
von Weltmarkt und Dorf.
Die Menschen, die Familien
trugen das volle Risiko,
wenn das Geschäft nicht mehr lief,
eine globale Wirtschaftskrise
eintrat.
Das war im 19. Jh.
immer mehr der Fall.
Dann mussten sie
von etwas anderem leben können.
Einige konnten das, weil sie noch
kleine Landwirtschaftsgüter hatten.
Andere kamen ins grosse Elend.
Hunderttausende fanden im 19. Jh.
auch noch den Weg über den Atlantik.
Wer genau ist reich?
Das war schon um 1850
nicht ganz klar.
Da verhungerten in der Schweiz
noch Menschen.
Es gab eine tatsächliche Hungersnot
wegen schlechter Ernte.
Man speiste die Menschen
mit etwas Geld ab,
damit sie das nächste Schiff in die
USA oder nach Südamerika nehmen.
Der Export von Armut
bedeutete im 19. Jh.
eine wesentliche Erleichterung
für die Schweiz.
Später, im 20. Jh.,
schob man bei Arbeitslosigkeit
ausländische Arbeitskräfte
zuerst ab.
Die Schweizer Wirtschaft
war immer sehr offen.
Ausländische Unternehmen
konnten sich unbürokratisch ansiedeln
und ausländische Arbeitskräfte
waren stets willkommen.
Jedoch nur,
solange sie benötigt wurden.
Die Wirtschaftskrise der 1970er-Jahre
z.B. wurde abgemildert,
indem über 200'000 sog. Gastarbeiter
das Land verlassen mussten.
Nun zu einem düsteren Kapitel
in der Schweizer Geschichte,
das lange nicht aufgearbeitet wurde:
Sklaverei.
Das Kapital für den Aufbau
einer Handelsfirma, die gross wurde,
kam im 18. Jh. z.B. im Raum Basel
häufig aus Investitionen,
die man im sog.
Atlantischen Dreieckshandel tätigte.
Familien rüsteten
auch Sklavenschiffe aus.
Sie handelten mit Dingen,
die in Afrika begehrt waren
und gegen die man
Sklaven eintauschen konnte.
Von daher hat auch die Schweiz Vor-
teile aus dem Sklavenhandel gezogen.
Die Familie De Pury z.B.,
aber auch die Familie Escher,
die Kaffeeplantagen in Kuba hatte.
Da entstand die erste Million
der Familie.
Wir wissen: Die erste Million
ist immer die schwierigste.
Es gibt die These
der Schweiz als Trittbrettfahrerin.
Man profitierte immer von dem,
was die grossen imperialen Mächte
weltweit so anstellten.
Die Schweiz hatte nie die Mittel,
Kanonenboote und grosse Truppen
irgendwohin zu schicken.
Andere Länder
hatten aber diese Mittel.
Z.B. als die USA die Japaner
zwangen, ihr Land zu öffnen.
Sie zwangen sie mit Kanonen,
ihr Land für den Handel
westlicher Firmen zu öffnen.
Da reiste auch
eine Schweizer Delegation hin
und schloss einen Freundschafts-
und Handelsvertrag ab.
* Rasselnde Klänge *
Es scheint, als habe die Schweiz
immer genau gewusst,
wo es auf der Welt
Geld zu verdienen gibt.
Heute ist die Schweiz so reich,
dass jeder achte Erwachsene
Dollarmillionär ist.
Aber ist dieser Reichtum
denn gerecht verteilt?
Die Schweiz hat, was
die Einkommensverteilung betrifft,
durchaus Werte,
mit denen sie im internationalen
Vergleich gut dasteht.
Die Vermögensverteilung
ist allerdings sehr ungleich.
Der Gini-Index misst, wie gerecht
oder ungerecht Vermögen verteilt ist.
Der Wert 100 ist am schlechtesten.
Dieser Wert würde bedeuten,
dass einer einzigen Person das
gesamte Vermögen eines Landes gehört.
Der Wert 0 würde bedeuten,
dass das Vermögen in einem Land
unter allen Einwohnern
absolut gleichmässig verteilt ist.
Die ungerechteste Vermögensverteilung
im Jahre 2019
hatten die Vereinigten Arabischen
Emirate mit einem Wert von 88,4.
Ebenfalls ziemlich ungerecht verteilt
war das Vermögen in Deutschland
und der Schweiz.
Beide mit dem gleich hohen Wert
von 77,9.
Etwas gerechter war Österreich
mit 73,9.
Die gerechteste Vermögensverteilung
aller Länder hatte Belgien
mit 60,2.
Es gibt auch in der Schweiz
Menschen,
die mit sehr wenig Geld
leben müssen.
Es gibt ländliche Regionen,
wo das relativ gut geht.
In den Städten
wird es sehr schnell prekär.
Da kann man nicht mehr
am Sozialleben partizipieren.
Wir verdienen mehr
als Deutsche oder Österreicher,
aber wir bezahlen auch viel mehr -
die Preise sind hier sehr hoch.
Man nicht nur das Einkommen
anschauen.
Man muss es mit den
Lebenshaltungskosten vergleichen,
um zu sehen,
was am Ende übrig bleibt.
Kann man sich in der Schweiz
tatsächlich nicht mehr leisten
als in Deutschland und Österreich?
Das Portal Länderinfo.de
hat dies im Jahr 2019 berechnet.
Es stützt sich dabei auf Zahlen
der OECD und der Weltbank.
Dies Studie kommt zum Schluss, dass
sich eine Schweizerin, ein Schweizer,
im Schnitt 11 % mehr leisten kann
als ihre Nachbarin, ihr Nachbar
in Deutschland.
Deutschland und Österreich
sind in etwa gleichauf.
Obwohl die Schweiz oftmals
als Hochpreisinsel angesehen wird,
bleiben letztlich den Schweizern,
wenn man das
kaufkraftbereinigt anschaut,
ca. 31'000 Euro,
während es in Deutschland
ca. 25'000 Euro
und in Österreich 26'000 Euro sind.
Schweizer können sich also im
Durchschnitt tatsächlich mehr leisten
als ihre Nachbarn
jenseits der Grenze.
Weshalb - denken Sie -
ist die Schweiz so reich?
Ich glaube,
das liegt an der Bevölkerung.
Dass sie sich
von Europa etwas abkapseln,
hat bestimmt einen Vorteil,
denke ich.
(Straumann) Das Verhältnis
der Schweiz zur EU ist sekundär
für den wirtschaftlichen Erfolg.
Erstens haben wir viele sehr reiche
Länder wie Dänemark, Niederlande,
und Regionen wie Norditalien.
Die sind auch Teil der EU, die
sind praktisch gleich wohlhabend.
Dann sind wir ohnehin
schon eng an die EU gebunden.
Wir sind de facto
in vielen Bereichen,
gerade wirtschaftspolitisch,
sehr eng verbunden.
Träte die Schweiz der EU bei,
würde sie weder viel reicher werden
noch würde sie verarmen.
Die Situation wäre sehr ähnlich.
Was denken Sie, aus welchem Grund
die Schweiz so reich ist?
Warum? Die zahlen nicht so hohe
Steuern wie in Deutschland.
Und ... Ähm ...
Ja ...
Weil sich dort wahrscheinlich
auch sehr viele Menschen ansiedeln -
wegen der Steuern.
Ich würde sagen, sie macht schon
seit vielen Jahren das Richtige,
wenn es z.B. darum geht, sich
mit dem Geld auseinanderzusetzen.
Seien es Steuern ...
Die Steuerbelastung für Unternehmen
ist in der Schweiz
vergleichsweise tief.
Das Wirtschaftsforschungsinstitut
BAK Economics
hat 2019 Regionen weltweit
miteinander verglichen.
Demzufolge ergibt sich in München
eine Steuerbelastung für Unternehmen
von 29,3 %,
in Wien 22,5 %
und in Basel 11 %.
Eine so tiefe Steuerbelastung gibt es
in einigen Kantonen der Schweiz,
z.B. in Zug.
Zug war bis in die 50er-Jahre
ein Agrarkanton.
Dann kamen findige Experten
aus Zürich auf die Idee,
dass man da ein Steuerdumping
installieren könnte,
um grosse Firmen anzulocken.
Erst waren es amerikanische
und später russische Firmen,
die sich niederliessen.
Die kamen natürlich einerseits
aus Neutralitätsgründen hierher,
da man über die Schweiz
sehr gut Geschäfte abwickeln kann,
auch wenn das Heimatland ein Embargo
gegen einen Drittstaat verhängt hat.
Andererseits
natürlich aus Steuergründen.
Die drei grössten Firmen der Schweiz
sind Rohstoffhandelsfirmen.
Die Schweiz ist der wichtigste
Rohstoffhandelsplatz der Welt.
Ein Viertel aller
weltweit gehandelten Rohstoffe
wird in der Schweiz abgewickelt.
Man spricht von Transithandel.
Die Waren
kommen nicht in die Schweiz.
Die werden in einem Exportland
aufgekauft
und werden auf der ganzen Welt
wieder verkauft.
Das Einzige,
was die Schweiz transitiert,
ist das Kapital.
Das ist
ein sehr bedeutendes Geschäft.
In der Schweiz relativ unsichtbar.
Man braucht hier
einen eingetragenen Firmensitz,
eine Adresskartei und ein Telefon.
* Schrilles Klingeln *
Gut, ja.
Rund 550 solche Handelsfirmen
gibt es in der Schweiz.
Nicht zuletzt auch
wegen der Neutralität des Landes.
Diese Firmen
haben auch mehrfach profitiert.
Nach dem Ersten und Zweiten Welt-
krieg oder während der Weltkriege
liefen sie zwar immer Gefahr,
auf die schwarze Liste zu kommen
wegen Handels mit dem Feind.
Die meisten überlebten aber
und wurden nicht liquidiert
und konnten nach Kriegsende
aus ihren gutbestückten Lagern
immer direkt wieder liefern.
Diese Schweizer Handelsfirmen waren
Profiteure der Kriege der anderen.
* Sirenen *
Die Schweiz hat
nicht so viel Historisches erlebt.
Dadurch konnte sich
das Land sehr schön entwickeln.
Sie hat sich nie in grosse Kriege
eingemischt und dort etwas verloren.
Alles, was wir hier haben,
mussten wir aufbauen -
oder unsere Vorfahren.
Das habt ihr in der Schweiz
natürlich nicht so gehabt.
Nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
war die Schweiz
in einer relativ guten Situation
mit unzerstörten Produktionsanlagen,
während die umliegenden Länder
durch den Krieg sehr zerstört waren.
Die Anlagen, die es noch gab,
wurden z.T. auch deportiert.
Das ist in der Schweiz
alles nicht passiert.
Man konnte mit der Produktion
anfangen.
Es gab einen Bedarf an Waren,
auf den die Schweiz unmittelbar
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
sehr schnell reagieren konnte.
* Dynamische swingende Klänge *
Die Neutralität war schon wichtig.
Man erklärte zu Beginn des Krieges,
man wolle nicht
am Krieg der anderen teilnehmen.
Nun heisst das aber nicht,
dass ein Land nicht trotzdem
in einen Krieg gerät.
Das sah man im Ersten Weltkrieg
bei Belgien.
Es lag in der Hauptangriffsschneise
und wurde sofort überrannt.
Kleine Länder oder Regionen
wollen immer neutral sein,
wollen immer Frieden, weil
sie aussenpolitisch schwach sind.
Und sie haben meist
eine gute Wirtschaft.
Dann ist es Glückssache,
ob man dummerweise im Weg steht
oder etwas weiter weg ist von den
militärischen Auseinandersetzungen.
* Arie Nr. 4 aus "Fidelio"
von Ludwig van Beethoven *
# Das Glück
dient wie ein Knecht für Sold.
# Es ist ein mächtig Ding,
das Gold, das Gold.
# Es ist ein mächtig Ding, das Gold.
# Ein mächtig Ding, ein mächtig Ding,
das Gold, das Gold.
Warum ist die Schweiz so reich?
Was denkt ihr,
was die Gründe dafür sein könnten?
Keine Ahnung.
Steuerhinterziehung und Nazigold?
Das hört man immer so.
Es gibt noch eine These,
weshalb die Schweiz im Zweiten
Weltkrieg nicht eingenommen wurde.
Nazideutschland
ist im Krieg zunehmend isoliert
und kann mit seinem Geld
nirgendwo mehr Rohstoffe kaufen.
Rohstoffe, die auch für
die Waffenproduktion benötigt werden.
In dieser Situation
ist die Schweiz nützlich.
Sie fungiert als Hehler,
nimmt Gold von den Nazis
und tauscht es
gegen Schweizer Franken ein.
Es ist Gold
der deutschen Nationalbank.
Raubgold, das die Deutschen
im Krieg erbeuteten,
und auch Gold
aus Konzentrationslagern.
Blieb die Schweiz wegen dieser
Hehlerfunktion vom Krieg verschont?
Das muss man in der
zeitlichen Staffelung betrachten.
Zu Kriegsbeginn war diese
Hehlerfunktion noch nicht sichtbar.
Das war der Moment,
wo die Bedrohung am grössten war,
wahrgenommen in der Schweiz.
Die Schweiz lag strategisch im
toten Winkel. Es passierte nichts.
Und dann kam schon im Sommer 1940
dieses Wirtschaftsabkommen
mit Deutschland zustande.
Und dann kamen diese Goldübernahmen.
Das ist keine Absicherung
gegen einen Angriff,
aber war wohl
doch mit ein Grund dafür,
dass Deutschland
die Schweiz nicht angriff.
Es stimmt, dass die Schweiz
wichtige Transaktionen durchführte.
Aber es ist falsch, zu sagen,
die Schweiz
sei deshalb nicht erobert worden.
Man kann das
bei diesem Vergleich erkennen:
Die Niederlande hatten eine
ähnliche Funktion vor 1939/1940.
Sie waren der Finanzplatz
Deutschlands.
Es bewahrte sie aber nicht davor,
erobert zu werden.
Was Judengold aus
den Konzentrationslagern anbelangt,
ist man zum Schluss gekommen,
dass davon etwas dabei war.
Aber für die Wirtschaftsgeschichte
spielt das
überhaupt keine wesentliche Rolle.
(Originalton) Die Nationalbank
spricht lieber über Zahlen
als über Moral. Da ist die Politik
weiter: Sie hat bereits vorgesorgt.
Wie damals bei Kriegsende
will die Schweiz mit Wohltätigkeit
gegen den schlechten Ruf kämpfen.
7 Mrd. Fr. sollen in eine Stiftung
für Solidarität gehen.
Sühne für nicht über alle Zweifel
erhabene Goldgeschäfte.
Der Handel im Zweiten Weltkrieg ...
... hat dem Renommee
natürlich sehr geschadet.
Nach 1945 war das Ansehen der
Schweiz ziemlich im Keller.
Da hat man mit Neutralität,
mit Hilfsprogrammen,
mit Hilfsprojekten versucht,
dieses Image des Profiteurs
wieder loszuwerden -
offensichtlich erfolgreich.
Die Neutralität war und ist
ein Erfolgsfaktor für die Schweiz.
Dabei war sie
gar nicht ihre eigene Idee.
Im 19. Jh. wird Napoleon besiegt
und Europa am Wiener Kongress
neu geordnet.
Die Grossmächte
können sich nicht einigen,
wer die Kontrolle
über das Alpenland hat.
Deshalb soll es neutral bleiben.
Das war
eine aufgezwungene Neutralität.
Es ist nicht so, dass die Schweiz
es sich ausgewählt hat,
dort neutral zu sein.
Aber sie hat diese Neutralität
vielleicht benutzt
und sie
zu einem eigenen Label gemacht.
Die Neutralität ist also
nichts originär Schweizerisches.
Ganz im Gegensatz
zur direkten Demokratie:
Sie ist weltweit einzigartig.
Ich muss noch den Kanton
und die politische Gemeinde ...
Ein Instrument der direkten
Demokratie ist die Volksinitiative.
Alle Schweizer Bürger/-innen
haben das Recht,
eine Initiative zu starten.
Schafft er oder sie es,
100'000 Unterschriften zu sammeln,
stimmt das Volk über das Anliegen ab.
Wenn das Volk Ja sagt, muss
das Parlament den Entscheid umsetzen.
Das hat eine Ventilfunktion.
Die Leute können mitteilen:
"Ihr habt da zu wenig gemacht,
bitte macht etwas."
Dadurch können keine
grossen Polarisierungen entstehen,
weil alle
irgendwie eingebunden sind.
Der Vorteil ist: Man muss das Volk
fragen. Man braucht gute Argumente.
Es ist schwierig,
in der Schweiz Politik zu machen.
Dafür haben wir
eine sehr grosse Stabilität,
was für die Wirtschaft gut ist.
Die Kompromissfähigkeit,
die wir auch im Bundesrat leben,
seit Jahrzehnten vorleben,
trägt auch zur Stabilität bei.
Es geht nicht um Regierungswechsel,
sondern um Konsensfindung.
Nicht wie in den meisten Ländern
üblich
eine Regierungschefin
oder ein Regierungschef
steuern die Geschicke des Landes,
sondern sieben Bundesrätinnen und
-räte aus vier Parteien gemeinsam.
So kann nicht ein Einzelner
plötzliche oder radikale Kurswechsel
vornehmen.
Die politische Stabilität
wurde uns oft als Grund
für den Reichtum der Schweiz genannt.
Gemäss unseren Expertinnen
und Experten
wurden schon bei der Gründung
der modernen Eidgenossenschaft
gute Grundlagen dafür geschaffen.
Wenn man von  d e r  Schweiz
im 19. Jh. spricht,
muss man sicher von der
Bundesstaatsgründung 1848 sprechen.
Da entstand die moderne Schweiz,
die sich 1874 eine
totalrevidierte neue Verfassung gab,
die die fortschrittlichste der Welt
war, kann man sagen.
Mit einer direkten Demokratie,
mit später dann Fabrikgesetzgebung,
dem allgemeinen Männerwahlrecht
sowieso -
die Frauen blieben
allerdings ausgeschlossen -,
mit der allgemeinen Schulpflicht.
* Rufe *
Ha, natürlich.
Ja, Bildung spielte eine Rolle.
Die Schulpflicht
wurde relativ früh eingeführt.
Der Gratisunterricht
war relativ früh da.
Es wurden beide Geschlechter
unterrichtet.
Das hat man
auch damit beliebt gemacht,
dass in der Schweiz über
ganz komplexe Fragen abgestimmt wird
und dass darum die Bildung
der einfachen Leute so sein muss,
dass sie verstehen, was sie da tun.
Das war eines der Argumente,
neben dem wirtschaftlichen Faktor.
Sie müssen rechnen können,
sie sollen sparen können,
Hausfrauen sollen Haushaltsbücher
führen können.
All das wurde auch gesagt.
Aber es war auch
die allgemeine Idee:
Sie müssen fit sein, damit sie
die Staatsgeschäfte verstehen.
Beim Thema Bildung schliesst sich
in unserem Film der Kreis
zwischen der erfolgreichen
Vergangenheit der Schweiz
und einer erfolgreichen Zukunft.
(Zaki) Bildung
ist der Schlüssel zum Erfolg.
Wenn die Schweiz weiterhin
eine hochgebildete Bevölkerung hat
mit einem hohen Grad an Kompetenzen
für Zukunftsberufe,
dann wird sie an der Spitze
der OECD-Länder bleiben
und ist weiterhin innovativ
und wettbewerbsfähig.
Was ich aber heute sehe,
beunruhigt mich.
Die ungleiche Verteilung
von Reichtum führt dazu,
dass das Thema Bildung
etwas weniger Beachtung bekommt.
Bildung
sollte die oberste Priorität haben.
Die Schweiz sollte
ihr ganzes Vermögen
in die Aus- und Weiterbildung
der Bevölkerung stecken.
Aber das passiert nicht.
Ich glaube, dass
diese Alleinstellungsmerkmale
tendenziell weniger wichtig werden.
Die Amerikaner wissen unterdessen
auch, wie man Banking macht.
Man kann sich nicht mehr so einfach
auf ein Spezialgebiet ...
... konzentrieren
und das den anderen verkaufen.
Wir haben hier doch,
auch wenn es sich etwas verändert,
immer noch
einen sehr breiten Wohlstand.
Also eine relativ breite
Partizipation am Wohlstand.
Daher sicher nicht
die schlechtesten Bedingungen.
Es hängt aber alles davon ab,
wie sich die Schweiz
nun international positioniert
und ob sie
auf eine kluge Art mitmacht.
Die führenden Branchen
zeigen jeweils auf,
wohin der Erfolg geht.
Im Moment sind die grössten, am
schnellsten wachsenden Unternehmen
Datenunternehmen, Tech-Unternehmen.
* Hüpfende glockige Klänge *
In Zukunft gibt es nicht
nur einen Wettbewerb darum,
wer die meisten Daten hat,
sondern wer die besten Programme
hat, um die Daten zu verarbeiten.
Also künstliche Intelligenz.
Diesbezüglich ist die Schweiz
nicht im Spitzenfeld.
Auch Europa entwickelt künstliche
Intelligenzen und forscht.
Aber im Vergleich mit der Marktmacht
in den USA und in Asien
ist Europa klar im Hintertreffen.
Es gibt viele Schweizer oder
in der Schweiz lebende Menschen,
die gute Ideen haben.
Beim Global Innovation Index
sind wir auf Platz 1.
Wir sind vor den USA platziert.
Umgesetzt wird es aber vielleicht
etwas zu wenig.
Aber die Forschungsideen sind da.
Ich bin überzeugt, dass die Schweiz
wirtschaftlich weiterhin
sehr attraktiv und stark sein wird.
Der einfachste Indikator
ist die Einwanderung.
Wenn ein Land so hohe Einwanderungs-
zahlen verzeichnet wie die Schweiz,
und zwar auf allen Ebenen,
von sehr gut qualifiziert
bis weniger gut qualifiziert, macht
sie offensichtlich vieles richtig.
Um die Länder, die das nicht haben,
muss man sich Sorgen machen.
Aber die Schweiz ist so begehrt.
Dadurch kommen immer wieder
sehr gute Leute in die Schweiz.
Ich mache mir
überhaupt keine Sorgen.
Es ist die Fortsetzung
der alten Geschichte.
Viele Meinungen zur Zukunft
und Vergangenheit der Schweiz.
Worüber sich die Expertinnen
und Experten einig sind:
Die Schweiz hatte
durch ihre geografische Lage
gute Ausgangsbedingungen.
Dann kamen Glück und Ideenreichtum
dazu,
clevere politische Entscheide
und eine Prise Schamlosigkeit.
(Mann) Tschüss, vielen Dank.
(Mehrere Kinder) Tschüss.
Und es gilt wohl die alte Regel:
Geld fliesst zu Geld.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Elisabeth Graf - 2021